[Music]
hey guys I'm Scott here with Tony at PAX
East we're gonna talk about a game
called dauntless that I know very little
about
but the Tony is actually played so Tony
just to start out with can you tell us
what dauntless is
sure so dauntless is very similar to
monster hunter if you're taking down
these big creatures and it comes from a
lot of X blizzard people so it's got a
nice art style to it it plays really
smoothly and kind of makes you want to
go fight those monsters so this is a
monster hunter game are there classes or
anything like that in the game so the
way you're thinking of classes is not
the way that this game does it when you
make a character you don't choose I want
to be a tank or I wouldn't be a robe or
something like that
it's all gear based okay so you choose
okay I'm gonna fight with an X I'm gonna
fight with a hammer I'm gonna fight with
a sword
swords kind of the go-to weapon for most
people I think it's you know got that
balance of agility and damage but as you
can see in the opening trailer the
hammer actually has sort of like a
rocket on the back of it that you can
boost yourself ahead with so each tool
also has sort of tricks like that that
you can use gotcha so it's not just
purely melee combat it's also weapons or
also tools in a way yeah weapons are
also tools that you can use to fight
these things the sword once you powered
up you can unleash like an area of
effect attack that damages the monster
and also sort of buffs your damage for a
little bit of time and of course the
axes and the Hammers they just hit
really hard right when just never hurts
nevertheless you're getting hit with it
yes if you're the monster it's gonna
hurt a lot so at the top you compare
this to a monster hunter game why you
like what makes this like monster hunter
so your team is out on the sky islands
hunting down these giant monsters and I
got to fight two of them I fought a
giant owl and I thought a giant Pangolin
one was sort of like a tutorial boss the
other one not so much of a tutorial boss
it was pretty tough to take down there's
no health meter on these things you just
kind of pound away at them until they go
down you can see like sort of scars and
flesh wounds forming as you fight them
so that's kind of your your visual cue
as to how well you're doing in this
fight but as you're finding these things
you need to concentrate sort of on
certain body parts so the Pangolin for
instance it has a rolling attack it sort
of rolls over you with all these
crystals on its back so if you get a
chance as it's sort of on its side if
you break up those crystals they'll do
less damage the next time they hit you
because there are fewer of them on its
back
and of course it's got a giant tail that
you want to slice off because once you
slice that off you can't really swing
his tail at you anymore and just to be
clear this is like a cooperative game
right the trailer made it look like it's
a multiplayer game yeah we played with
four players I'm not really sure what
the total count is but with four people
pretty fun to take down a giant monster
cool so that's all the info we have on
dauntless but be sure to use like and
subscribe on youtube and tune in to
games.com for all of our content from
PAX East to 2017
[Music]
you